[Music]
all right we are back and it's time for
our second installment of everybody's
favorite segment facts are your friends
where we have simple conversations about
complex ideas
is this everybody's favorite segment i'm
going with that i'm
in the greatest segment ever produced
ever i don't know that that thing jay
leno used to do on the street was pretty
funny that was great but
a quick second place to that one facts
are your friends simple conversations
about complex topics all right so the
other day i was being interviewed on a
guy's podcast guy was awesome real
hospitable we're having a good time and
he was like a like like a like a
guy and
in my new book i have a
a
line
or a paragraph where i'm talking about
i don't think gen z i don't think
millennials
are this dysfunctional weak lazy group
of people
i don't think that they are cowards or
somehow inherently deficient or broken
and he said during the interview
like there's this perception right
they're just weaker and softer and if we
could just get back to the old days
and he said you don't really believe
that do you
like i know you wrote that in your book
but you don't really think that do you
i thought about the gin's ears that i
know and i thought about the millennials
that i know
and i said yeah i absolutely believe
that and he's like come on man seriously
look around
and i get where he's coming from and he
was looking at the data like everybody
else and he's looking at the mental
health crisis and the rise of anxiety
and the rise of depression and the rise
of loneliness and even our own
ramsay solutions research the the we did
a big research survey here on people's
mental health and shows that gen z's and
millennials are more likely to struggle
with mental health challenges than other
generations and if you take that one
step back
right look at the number of kids going
to law school the number of kids going
to med school look at the
uh obesity rates and the plummeting
physical fitness and the rise in
diabetes i mean you can point to all
these things
and say yeah see they're just sitting
around they're playing video games
they're being lazy they don't do crap uh
yeah
that's one side it's one side of it
having worked with them for the last 20
years walking alongside
thousands and thousands and thousands of
them and then being steeped in the data
in the research here's another
perspective
the moment they were born
they were told hey by the way by the
time you're like 30
the climate will have killed us um
because all these people are screwed up
the environment so you're going to be
dead you're not going to have kids
the moment they were born was in and
around 9 11
and not only were they around 9 11 but
they have been around adults who have
lost their freaking minds
who stay glued to these little cellular
devices who are obsessed with
dramatic
sensational news stories and uh and the
rise of 24-hour news and the rise of the
murder podcast where when our regular
day doesn't suck enough let's listen to
how somebody else's life sucks even
worse
and
they've been told that they can't trust
the news their churches the government
their parents you can't even trust
yourself why because you have a
diagnosis you've got something wrong
with you
they've been the guinea pig for
world-changing innovations like social
media and smartphones they've been
diagnosed with things that nobody heard
of a hundred years ago they didn't exist
and some of that's good actually some of
that we've been able to go hey that's
actually trauma this is actually
depression this is an important thing
but some of it has been madness
some of them have just been doped up
because they can't sit in a room for
nine hours and not move
they've had
processed food shoved into their faces
since they were born
they've had p.e and movement in laughter
and play enjoy taking out of the schools
they've had athletics taken away they've
had art taken away they've had music
classes taken away
they don't go to concerts they just
stream them
because mom and dad are working two
full-time jobs plus two side hustles and
i don't have time to take you to that
we're not gonna do that
so when i look at it from that
perspective
of course they're it completely burned
out
of course they're exhausted and fried
and anxious and depressed
of course they go towards a video game
because the real world they've inherited
is on fire literally on fire
it takes an especially strong resilient
creative and adaptable generation to
take on what the world has dumped in
their laps and yes i know my dad told me
he used to have to do nuclear weapon
drills when he was a kid
he did
because there were nukes in cuba pointed
right at he was in houston pointed right
at him
i get the world's always been bad
but there's been anchors in education
and we're gonna be all right in an
american spirit in or a whatever spirit
is there's been collective theology that
binds a group of people together and
says hey there's something bigger that
we're serving here
and this generation has
none of that
all i have is caustic it's all coming
down
and so when i see a kid
in a local university when i see a high
school kid
making it work it's incredible and when
i see kids that are strong struggling
under the weight of the nonsense my
heart breaks for him
and pointing fingers that i'm calling
him lazy that's not gonna help
yelling and screaming at the news not
gonna help
sitting down and saying hey i'm sorry
that we've given this to you this way
let's do something else
if you spend time with young people it's
incredible they can be extraordinary in
their vision
and their hopes and the way they think
well i guess this is how the world we've
been handed this is how we're gonna have
to make do
and so my biggest takeaway from this
whole exchange with the interviewer was
this we need to stop defining strength
as being silent stoic and working 90
hour weeks just flexing and crushing
on the flip side we need to stop
considering any sign of struggle or
dysfunctional weakness instead
maybe strength is choosing to move
forward despite the uncertainty to
grieve despite the pain to choose
healing despite the fear
i went to college and got out
in the in
in
2000
and the world was my like it's all like
you can do anything
and now to graduate after two years of
having to do online back in school back
to school online online back in school
school's cancelled
by the way you're just going to be dead
from climate change anyway and plus
inflation is going to kill you and by
the way there's gonna be world war three
and you're gonna get nuked so why even
what are you even doing whatever you're
doing go play fortnite and just move on
with your day
to graduate college in that and say no
no no i'm gonna keep pushing forward i'm
gonna change the world
that my friends is strength
that my friends is resilience that my
friend is saying fine
not by my hand but in my lap this is
what got dropped here
i'm gonna make do and not only am i
gonna make do i'm gonna make changes i'm
gonna make this thing better
so hear me say
stop throwing grenades at other
generations if you will
they are people like us trying to figure
it out and i'm grateful for the young
folks figuring it out and if you're a
young folk and you're stuck and you
don't know what you're doing and you
found yourself 100 pounds overweight or
you don't like yourself or you're in a
marriage that you didn't know how you
stumbled into it reach out and ask
somebody for help because there's a
different way to do this and if you're
55 or 65 or 45 or 35 and your whole
identity is based on
i'm telling you it's gonna come down
stop
reach over and tell somebody i'm not
okay reach over and say hey you know
what else is cool rest
holding hands
love
compassion kindness
patience those are virtues too